[Music]
Andy my own Andy Richter has been
working apparently on a comedy bit he
told me about it
just before the show started he said he
wants to try it out tonight it's cool
with me are you ready to do this thing
Andy I am ready Conan are you ready in
the booth Billy ready all right okay my
Annie you don't know what this is but go
ahead remember this remember this
remember this remember this
okay I'm sorry Andy
and II could you just are you doing
what's wrong well that's not a comedy
piece all you're doing is saying member
this and showing pictures of stuff well
yeah but that's just like the first part
I mean now it's gonna change and you
know I'm sorry I cut you up before I
change it alright alright I'm fine go
ahead remember him remember them okay
wait a minute what stop Andy again you
just changed member this to remember him
and member her yeah yeah people like to
remember stuff I mean what do you have
against it you guys like that right
[Applause]
anybody I'm sorry anybody can do that
Billy give me a screen yeah remember
this remember this ahem remember her
remember him okay wait a man take a town
bill
wait a minute those were awful yeah see
it's not so easy is it
no Andy that's not fair I'm trying to do
a comedy show and now you've upset the
crowd well well I think I can help
remember this
[Applause]